Let's talk about the current
opportunities and challenges
that you'll face as you
enter the labor market.
My first question is,
are these the best
of times, or the worst of
times to be looking for a job
and starting your career?
Well, let's take a look at some
of the labor market realities
that you face.
You all recall what we referred
to as the Great Recession
of 2007 and 2009?
This chart shows
just how many jobs we
lost during that time period.
Well, the good news is
that, in fact, 2015--
finally-- was a great year
for job growth in the US.
We made a big dent in
closing the jobs deficit,
by creating nearly 2
and 1/2 million jobs.
So now we only need
another 3 million more
to close the full job deficit.
Let's hope we keep making
progress like we did last year.
No guarantees, given the
shaky world economy we're in.
So we have to keep pressing
government and business
leaders to keep the job
growth going strong.
That's challenge number one.
But that's only the
beginning of the challenge.
Recall what the
Occupy movement said,
that 1% of the top earners
are getting all of the income?
Well, they were right.
Over 50% of income
growth in the last decade
has come to the top 1%.
And we have to go way
back here, to 1928,
to have a situation where we get
that much unequal distribution
of income.
So we do have an income problem.
But it wasn't always this way.
From the end of World War II--
down here about 1947,
1948-- all the way through
till about 1980,
we saw an economy
where wages, and productivity,
and profits moved together.
Later on we're going
to talk about this
as the era of the post-World
War II social contract.
But something happened here.
Note, after 1980s, productivity
continued to grow by over 80%,
but wages and
compensation flat-lined.
The average worker in
the United States economy
has only seen about a 9%
wage increase since 1980.
And in fact, if you don't
have a college degree
your wages have gone down,
relative to the cost of living
during this time period.
So while in the
early stage, we had
what President Kennedy said, "a
rising tide lifts all boats."
Everybody worked hard
and shared in the gains.
We have seen something
happen since 1980
that has changed that.
Let's now focus a little
bit more carefully on just
what happens if you
are entering the labor
market after finishing
high school or college
at this point in time.
Many of you will start
off as unpaid interns,
or in part time
jobs, or in jobs that
don't use the full
education that you've
worked so hard to achieve.
You'll be what we
call underemployed.
And it's not surprising that
given that, many of your cohort
are experiencing very low
levels of job satisfaction.
In fact, the lowest levels that
we have seen in many years.
Back in the 1980s,
this red line shows,
that people under the age
of 25 were like others--
more than 50% were
satisfied with their wages,
their hours of work,
and their opportunities
to learn on the job.
But now, these numbers have
declined to a little over 35%.
And so only about one
third of young people
are satisfied with their jobs.
How does this really affect you?
Well, the economic
evidence is very clear--
if you start off as many of
you are experiencing now,
in a low-income jobs that
don't use your full skills that
you've been educated for, or
you start off as a paid or even
an unpaid intern, or you start
off in part-time work in hotels
or restaurants, or
other retail areas,
you're going to experience
about 10 years-- or even more--
of suppressed income and lack
of opportunities for growth.
Does it have to be this way?
I don't believe
that for a moment.
There is no iron
law of economics
that produce these results.
It's the results
of bad policies,
of our institutions and
the way in which we govern.
We're failing to catch
up with the changing
workforce, and the
changing nature of work.
And we can do better.
And in fact, many
firms are doing better.
Some companies are way ahead
in providing good jobs.
A lot of innovation is
happening at the local level
in start-ups, in
nonprofit organizations,
in state and local governments.
We're going to look at
some of those innovations
in our next video, and ask how
you can join this process so
that we can improve the work
life of everyone going forward.